in this lesson we're going to practice
naming alkenes and alkynes I put a link
in the video description to blank copies
of these problems so you could practice
by solving them first and then watch the
video if you'd like let's get started
with a problem that involves an alkene
and alkyne in the same molecule as
always with nomenclature problems we
need to start by identifying our longest
carbon chain if we count from this end 1
2 3 4 5 and if we count from up here
it'll be the same 1 2 3 4 5 so we can
circle either this or this chain here
now we need to figure out which end to
number from this end or this end well we
want to use the end where we hit the
multiple bond first so we're going to
start numbering here on the right okay
now let's put together our suffix at the
four position we have a group hanging
off
that's a methyl so we're going to begin
this name with four methyl now we need
to name our chain it has 5 carbons so it
would be a pentane we have an alkene and
alkyne in it so it's actually going to
be a Penta nine I stopped at pent here
because now we actually need to define
the position within the chain where we
find our alkyne since we're naming this
as in a nine the alkyne begins at the 3
carbon so we need to add in a number 3
before we define our alkyne now if there
just were an alkyne this would be een
but since we're continuing the name we
have to drop that final e to tell where
our alkyne is our alkyne is at the 1
position so actually we can completely
leave it out and just write een ein or
we can define it a little bit better
using the number one because the alkyne
begins at number one in the chain
putting it all together this compound is
for methyl pent 3 een 1/9 let's do
another a nine example here we've added
on just an extra methyl group so we know
that's lengthened our chain by one and
we can circle it in the same way
as we did on this example now we need to
figure out which end to number from if
we look at this we see if we numbered
here the alkene would be at the two
position one two oh and the alkyne would
also be at a two position so when we're
given this choice we pick the alkene to
number first so in this case we're going
to number from left to right let's go
ahead and add in our prefix okay now we
have six carbons in our chain
so that's hexane for the parent alkane
so let's write on our hex now even
though the numbering priority favored
the alkene the suffix is set up the same
so this is still in a nine now our
alkene starts on the number two and our
alkyne begins on number four putting
that all together we get two methyl hex
two een four ein ok let's try a cyclic
example here we have one two three four
five six carbons within the ring and we
want to number so that this bromine atom
is number one now we need to figure out
if we number clockwise or in the
counterclockwise direction the answer
here is clockwise because we want to
number each end of the alkyne first so
we continue along this alkyne the second
position gets the two and then we can
finish numbering our ring for six carbon
atoms the parent alkane would be
cyclohexane so we're going to use the
hex name in our suffix what about our
prefix well we have one substituent at
the one position so we'll write in one
bromo cyclo hexa start now in this
example we have a dying we have two
alkenes within this molecule and so we
would usually drop the a but in this one
since it's going to be followed by dying
we'll put cyclo hexa now we needed to
find where these two alkenes are within
our ring this one starts at the one
position and this one begins at the four
position so we'll add in those numbers
into our name here
the final part of our name is dying to
account for our two double bonds let's
try a few more alkenes and practice
double bond geometry here's our example
our longest carbon chain is kind of
obvious going just right across here now
which end do we start numbering from we
want to number so that we hit the double
bond first so we'll start on the left
now to start our prefix bromine B comes
in the alphabet before C for chlorine so
we'll start with bromine I went ahead
netted the chlorine in there too now we
need to specify where our double bond
begins and that's on carbon 2 so we can
add on the suffix 2 n but there's
something special about this molecule
that we haven't talked about yet here
there are two different groups on this
side of the double bond and here there
are also two different groups on this
side on carbon 2 we have chlorine and a
methyl and on carbon three we have
methyl and a hydrogen atom that's
implied that I've not drawn in in our
first example we had the same group on
carbon 2 we had two methyls but the
chlorine here could be on this side of
the bond or this side of the bond and
that would make a different molecule so
we actually need to define where
chlorine is so taking both sides of the
double bond we want to figure out if the
high priority groups are on the same
side which would be a z alkene or on
opposite sides which would be an e
alkene to do this we pick the group with
the higher molecular mass so on carbon 2
this is going to be chlorine now on this
side on carbon 3 we have a hydrogen atom
the lowest mass compound that we can
have and a carbon so this side is our
higher priority group these two groups
are on the same side of the alkene so
this is a z alkene that designation goes
right out in front and is very important
so don't forget it
here's another example
obviously our longest carbon chain is
here I'll go ahead and circle that let's
number our carbons starting near the end
with the double bond nine carbons makes
this a non mean let's write up our
prefix first chlorine is at the eighth
position so eight chloro and then we
have a non - to define where the double
bond starts okay now we need to think
about our double bond geometry let me
add in the hydrogen atoms so on either
side the choices between hydrogen and
carbon here at carbon two we have a
hydrogen atom and a methyl the carbon
atom is going to have the higher
priority and on carbon three right here
we have an H and a carbon atom and so
this group over here gets higher
priority we can see from our stars that
the higher priority groups are on
opposite sides of the alkene now if this
is an alkene so we'll put that right out
in front
I was once taught a funny trick for
remembering double bond geometry for the
Z alkene the high priority groups are on
the same side so you can say on the same
side to remember this let's do a final
example okay at first glance this looks
almost identical to this problem but
it's in fact very different when there's
an alcohol in the molecule it takes
priority over the naming of the alkene
in both numbering and in the suffix and
so this compound is named as an enol and
we start numbering from the side closer
to the alcohol we again have an e double
bond so let's start with that then we
get our nonane part of the name the
alkene begins on the seven position now
and the alcohol had priority and it's
the last part of our name that's at the
two position okay let's summarize the
major takeaways from this lesson
numbering begins at the side of the
molecule that first hits the alkene or
the L kind but if you have a choice you
number so that the alkene gets the lower
number
when numbering in rings make sure you
hit both carbons of the double-bond
first and then continue around your ring
if we think about splitting the double
bond in half when there are different
groups on either side of this double
bond we need to think about Z and a
geometry finally we saw that alcohols
have priority over alkenes in both
numbering and in the suffix KP here if
you learn something give me a thumbs up
on the way out and for more chemistry
subscribe to my channel